Vladimir Putin has visited Russian
occupied mariopol in Ukraine the city is
in the Donetsk region which was annexed
by Moscow last year the Russian
president drove around several districts
of the city on Saturday and then was
shown restoration work at a theater and
the university Putin's trip comes after
he traveled to Crimea to Mark the ninth
anniversary of its annexation from
Ukraine and a deal allowing the export
of Ukrainian grain from the Black Sea
ports has now been extended Ukraine was
seeking an extension of four months but
Russia only wanted 60 days let's bring
in Stephanie Decker from key for more on
that grain deal this was expected was it
not Steph
it was expected in a way to be renewed
in the real sticking point and it's
interesting the United Nations being
very diplomatic if you will in its
language when it announced that it would
be extended also the Turkish leadership
both the UN and turkey uh are the
interlocutors if you will between Russia
and Ukraine when it comes to this deal
saying that the deal had been extended
but not talking specifically about how
long the deal stipulates it should be
extended by 120 days the sticking point
now from Moscow is it only wants to
extend it for 60 days because it says
that sanctions on things like its
banking system and insurance are
actually affecting its own exports which
isn't upholding uh the part of the deal
that affects Russia so it's clear
reading between the lines that these
negotiations are continuing about quite
how long it is set to be renewed the
issue is particularly for the farmers
here we've been talking to them is that
they need long-term stability when it
comes to planning the Harvest here is
around June the new uh Farmers year if
you will starts in July so if this is
going to be extended for 60 days or even
for 120 days which is four months we
were being told that it simply isn't
enough the minimum really what is needed
for stability is a year but at the
moment that is certainly not on the
table
um and again it's hugely significant
Russia controls uh the Black Sea this is
what Ukraine needs to ship its wheat
grain sunflower oil the biggest producer
in the world which is why it has such a
global impact which is why this deal is
so important and certainly Russia holds
a lot of Leverage when it comes to that
and tell us more about Vladimir Putin's
visit to mariopo
well I think you probably just showed
pictures of the Russian president
driving himself around the city it's the
first time he visits the city since uh
the War Began it's also three days after
the deadliest anniversary you may
remember
um Russia bombing the theater in Mari
Apple Maria Paul endured a Savage
assault that theater was Sheltering
hundreds of civilians
um and that was bombed on the 16th of
March in one of the deadliest incidents
of this war well now almost a year later
he is touring the city talking about
reconstruction it comes off the back of
also visiting Crimea on the ninth
anniversary of crimea's annexation and
also a defiant sign I think showing him
traveling the fact that now the Russian
president is liable to be arrested in
123 countries when it comes to this
arrest warrant issued by the
international criminal court well
certainly he doesn't face that danger
when it comes to the territories that
Russia has annexed so yes first time
we've seen the Russian president touring
these areas properly talking about
reconstruction but of course
particularly when it comes to Mario Paul
that city was hugely devastated by the
Russians in the war last year thank you
so much Stephanie Decker reporting from
Kiev